because it's a big stupid jellyfish i
love that that's mark that's you yelling
at yourself right yes yes i uh
i am calling myself a big stupid
jellyfish hi i'm jennifer hale and i'm
mark mir and today we're going to be
breaking down some of our favorite mass
effect moments
we should go
we really should you've been given
command of an advanced human warship for
your missions is there anything you'd
like to say about it
i've had enough of your snide
insinuations
it did it escalated so quickly what do
you have for breakfast i don't know i
mean it's possible to be antagonistic
towards the reporter all the way through
and then you know the punch doesn't uh
come so abruptly my good friend april
bannigan who is voicing kalisa el jalani
and we've had many a laugh about that
scene i want to know have there been any
reenactments we did re-enactments of not
one but two punches one of shepard to
the reporter and one of the reported
shepherd at the big mass effect file
from the party here in edmonton in fact
so april asked for one of of me punching
her i said all right but we have to
immediately take one of you punching me
how do you justify running away while
millions of people on earth die
is that the best we can i've had enough
of your tabloid journalism
ha
you want some
yes and of course if you miss that
second renegade interrupt she slugs you
and knocks you on your butt i i i've
forgotten about the headbutt though
why can't it act in an orderly unlawful
manner
because it's a big stupid jellyfish i
love that that's mark that's you yelling
at yourself right yes yes i uh i am
calling myself a big stupid jellyfish in
that thing
i'm also the henna i think most of the
hannah you encounter blasto included so
that that line was always very special
for me because i i knew i wasn't hurting
anyone's feelings except my own i loved
watching that clip because again i loved
watching mark yell at mark but i mean
sometimes it's you yelling at me because
i think i'm always the handler even when
it's you so i could never yell at you
though in actual life
you have got to be kidding me
therefore as a faithful servant of the
unkindlers we too must serve the reapers
you
big stupid jellyfish i sort of wanted
the sort of more ethereal feel to them
and uh i i had the opportunity to
actually go in first and create the sort
of baseline sound of a bunch of the mass
effect races because i was brought in
before i was cast as commander shepard
to essentially do a presentation to the
devs on okay here's what a typical
solarium might sound like hate waiting
for culture analysis never fast enough
here's what a typical voles might sound
like in this shared space i aid my
fellow volus and i know that one of the
initial ideas behind the hand are
they're telepathic as a species as a
whole they're pacifists except for
blasto that sort of informed the vocal
choice for those guys this is krogen
liquor rincon
you'll set off radiological alarms after
you're drinking should i pour you a
quantity
hell yeah
put more of the stuff in the
thing more stuff goes in your funeral
sister
[Music]
there it is
i love that it's absolutely scripted
what we talked about in the direction is
how drunk
do you want to be are you just a little
drawn hit me again are you
elijah
put more of the stuff in the thing
more stuff goes in it was degrees of
drunk i think we tried it different ways
i love drunk drunk is so fun i don't
which is hilarious because i actually
don't drink much at all but i love
playing a drunk what do you mean acting
drunk we just recorded this in a bar in
edmonton
it was it was a challenging day i'll
admit
uh the next day we took off no it was uh
it was a lot of fun to get to do that
scene of course and uh we did i i think
we had the similar experience we played
around with various levels of drunk and
how exactly how blotto shepard is do it
hit me again let's have another one i
think i did at least one take where it
was just
unintelligible like
stuff
the stuff goes in yeah yeah baloney you
know like just
just completely off the rails i should
go
i should go i should go i should go i
should go and of course you know it
wasn't strictly i should go there slight
variation sometimes like i have to go i
should keep going but it would it always
seemed to come back to i should go
that's the one that was like yeah that's
that is the catch phrase i should go i
just remember when we recorded it
because a lot of the time in games when
you have a repeated line of dialogue
they'll reprint and i remember asking
the first couple times oh are we gonna
reprint no
oh okay okay let's do it be going and
then like the seventh or eighth time i'm
like i should go yeah let's do it
fifteen okay yeah it's that line
yep yep let's just do it yep
i should go
whatever i didn't know it was going to
become a catchphrase among fans or that
that they would become this thing that
ends up being on you know licensed
merchandise and whatnot
but uh i did it did sort of become a
running gag with me and caroline and the
technicians because
whenever i needed to actually take a
bathroom break i would just you know
stop and go i have to go and they would
they would know what i meant and then
okay we'll take five by the spirits
shepherd in my store and i do love that
he's wearing camo armor because he
worked at the gun stores
i don't suppose i could convince you to
record an advertisement for me
sure you could can we work out a
discount a discount i'd name my
firstborn after you if you ask
can we record it now just speak towards
my console i'm commander shepard and
this is my favorite store on the citadel
[Music]
no other gun shop has that kind of
endorsement oh if he only do i certainly
give that endorsement to any number of
things any number of things are my
favorite what have you on the citadel
this is my favorite store on the citadel
this was one that was more geared
towards yes this could actually become a
thing because it's an actual in-joke in
the game and i love that shepard gets
away with just like giving this
endorsement to anyone who asked for and
getting discounts in return this thing
goes sideways and we both end up there
meet me at the bar
i'm buying
we're a team garrus
there's no shepherd without vacarion
so you better remember to duck i do love
the way you could have long deep
relationships with characters in this
thing and when we were recording spoiler
alert the uh latest scenes with garris
i'll just say it was so well written
that i was in the booth and the way the
setup was caroline was directing from
edmonton and she would skype in with us
and what i would normally hear in that
process is i would do a take and then i
would hear her chat to the engineer
saying okay uh keep this take do this
you know marry this that or let's do it
again or whatever and so i get to this
part of the script and the whole see you
in the bar
and i go to say the line and i'm in you
know living that scene
and i'm about to burst into tears and
all i could think was shepard does not
cry so just
so i said hold on
and i took a second i was like
you know and i stepped back up to the
mic and i
you know i bid it back and i delivered
the line
and i didn't hear caroline i didn't hear
that okay let's you know i just heard
nothing and i was like did we lose her
did we lose the line
and all i heard was
hold on
i was like oh it got hurt too
that was really fun
and painful and fun
it's the life of an actor right speaking
of super intimate scenes uh here's
here's a little trivia for you my wife
belinda cornish is actually in the games
as well and she's actually the very
first voice you hear in the first mass
effect she's the alliance computer
welcome to alliance military database
but she also did some uh demo dialogue
and like you know just some scratch
placeholder dialogue uh for some scenes
including uh the very intimate scene
that shepard has with tally of course
ash ash recorded it but uh they needed
some place will just
to make sure that all the size and
sexy sounds uh matched up together
so belinda recorded that uh
that tally's half of that uh we did
record separately however so it was
still just as as mortifying as jennifer
described because we're alone in the
booth each making you know you know our
separate sessions making the sexy sounds
so uh yeah we call those moan overs
[Music]
they didn't get into specificity of like
now we want a sound that sounds like
this and now we want no it was more that
we would do those scenes and
it's not like they would just like
replay the the same sexy sounds from you
know it's like we're doing the sexy
session we'll just plug it in whatever
you would play out those scenes and then
the sexy sounds would develop
organically shall we say
commander shepard and prothean partner
of undetermined ethnic origin
welcome to the spectre club
you know what blasto
i think you're just a big stupid
jellyfish how did you become a spec i
loved the citadel dlc so much because it
was just a big love letter from bioware
to the fans you know it was just such a
a beautiful like i needed that party i
needed to hang out with everybody and
i'm so glad that i got to it was the
culmination of everything and it's
basically the last thing that we worked
on so
it was we we all i'm sure had that same
feeling of like okay this is the last
thing and it sort of helps that the
citadel dlc is sort of built around this
big reunion of every character that is
in your squad from across all three
games you get to be in the same room
with all of them at the same time it had
that sort of celebratory finale feel to
it and let's face it it is jam-packed
with fan service and in jokes that have
been built up over the the three games
previous over the course of many years
and even bringing in things like that
may have come from the fandom you know
like the the bit where shepard's locked
in the vault and like you know they said
i should go do i sound like that i
should go i should go maybe it's i
should go
i should go
i should go for me personally my
favorite thing that i got to do instead
and there's a lot of favorite things i
got to do instead of dlc but at the top
of the list was shepard finally meeting
blasto face to face and you actually and
i'm voicing both of them so you've got
blasto the hannah specter from you know
from the movies and the other character
that's there with them is a vorcha so
i'm doing all three of those characters
in the scene so that was just felt like
bioware did that just for me and i
really appreciate it
[Music]
you